está sola el parlamento europeo que
asegura que cooperará con las
autoridades judiciales belgas por el
caso de corrupción que vincula a
eurodiputados con sobornos cataríes este
lunes empezó la última sesión plenaria
de estrasburgo que terminará con toda
probabilidad con la destitución de la
vicepresidenta de la eurocámara Eva kyli
es estado a la vicepresidenta mencionada
de todas las tareas y responsabilidades
vinculadas con su cargo y he convocado
una reunión extraordinaria de
presidentes de los grupos para ejecutar
el procedimiento del artículo 21 y
finalizar el mandato de la
vicepresidenta para proteger la
integridad de esta cámara este lunes
también rompieron el silencio altos
cargos de la comisión El Ejecutivo
comunitario insiste en agilizar su
propuesta de crear un órgano
independiente que controle la ética de
todas las instituciones europeas
las acusaciones contra la vicepresidenta
del parlamento europeo son muy graves y
sabemos que generan serias
preocupaciones porque se trata de la
pérdida de la confianza de la gente de
nuestras instituciones europeas exigimos
honestidad e integridad Más allá de
estos actos estándares
Kylie es la representante Europea de
mayor Rango entre los cuatro detenidos
en Bélgica acusados de participación en
una organización criminal lavado de
dinero y corrupción en el marco de una
supuesta recepción de sobornos de Qatar
a cambio de defender en Bruselas
posiciones favorables al actual
anfitrión del mundial de fútbol
hoy el mundial de fútbol de Qatar es una
prueba de cúmula diplomacia del deporte
puede conseguir una transformación
histórica en el país con reformas que
inspiran el mundo árabe yo solo digo que
Qatar está a la vanguardia en derechos
laborales la autoridad de lucha contra
la corrupción de Grecia ha congelado los
activos de Kylie en su país por otro
lado la justicia belga Pide al
parlamento europeo que le retire la
inmunidad para poder seguir con el
proceso judicial